each year Microsoft Research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
great thank you very much for coming
today
Maria kefir OVA is going to be giving a
talk on her work and Marika Maria is
doing her master's degree currently at
the camellias University in Slovakia and
in particular doing research at the
Research Center for quantum information
at the Slovak Academy of Science and
much of her work has been supervised by
Daniel negai and Maria has worked for
the previous two summers at the
Institute for quantum computing in
Waterloo and today she's gonna be
talking about some work that I'm really
excited about on showing quantum
speed-up by quantum annealing thank you
very much ok so thank you Nathan for
introduction and also thanks for having
me here I will tell you something about
my recent work with Rhonda soma and also
my supervisor Daniel my guy when we were
back in Slovakia and we asked ourselves
ok so we asked also this question so can
we get an exponential speed-up with the
adiabatic computation and we know that
there is an equivalence between
adiabatic quantum computation and
certain model but could we do it using
some very natural algorithm with a
sparse simple Hamiltonian and in this
talk I will tell you that the answer is
yes for the given problem called grow
trees that I will talk about this
problem was solved previous soft
previously with quantum works due to
Andrea Charles and others but we use new
adiabatic quantum computation approach
so I will talk then about quantum
adiabatic quantum computation and
finally I will present the new
algorithms which we made
so what start with grow trees we have
two binary trees which are glued
together with the random cycle we could
glue it together just
connecting the leaves from trees but
when we do it this way all vertices will
have degree 3 except for these two guys
the entrance and the exist which are
somehow special this way so this and our
goal is basically to go through this
blabbering starting at entrance and go
to the exit part since the depth of 1/3
is some n then we have exponential
number of vertices here and how adjacent
symmetries would be exponential so
that's why the problem is given as an
Oracle problem so we start with the key
for the entrance vertex and the Oracle
and Oracle when we input the label of a
given vertex it will give us labels of
the neighboring vertices vertices free
if we are somewhere in the middle of
trees or two if the vertices if the
vertex was entrance of or exit and also
we could possibly try to guess these
labels but the labels can be strong
larger strings so it's exponentially
unlikely to try good vertex to try a
good label and succeed and our goal is
to find the exit key exit extra label to
the exit vertex so we start here and we
ask Oracle which way we want to go and
we need to find this vertex at the
opposite part of growth trees so the
most the easiest thing we could possibly
do it would be to try some random walks
and when we start from entrance
everything is easy until we get to the
other trees so here it doesn't matter
where we go every time we go to the
right direction
but when we cross the middle point we
have every time bigger chance to go back
then to and continue the world to the
right way so after several steps we will
start returning and it would take us
exponentially sure number of steps to
reach the exit vertex just with random
walk okay but we could use also memory
and try to put a thread through our ring
or our vertices that we already know but
enrich others and other people show that
this is not possible
so even if we allow ourselves memory no
classical algorithm could succeed and
travels the glue trees in the lesser
than exponential number of steps it
doesn't have to be it's randomly growth
somehow yeah
okay yeah it's randomly good from this
part to this part so that oh oh degrees
do be great
this will be free - yeah well doesn't
have to be silk but
okay so what about quantum case could we
go
somehow efficiently from here to here
and we will see them the answer is yes
but first we need to define in the
problem in quantum settings so we start
in the end step and trance state and we
have access for these free Oracle's
first one is the adjacency matrix of the
glue trees which will serve as our
Hamiltonian and also we have projectors
on entrance which is easy because we
already know the state and projector on
the exit which is address state we of
degree 2 other than direct entrance and
the goal is to prepare exit state
eventually so we need to end in a state
which will be overlapped with the exit
state so then when we measure it we
could get exit state with high
probability and this way we could repair
it probabilistically and the way how we
can traverse good trees is using quantum
walk which are in some sense quantum
analog of continuous time random walks
or diffusion so continues time quantum
walks on graphs are defined by graph its
vertices are our state and the edges
give possible connections between state
so the adjacency matrix is our
Hamiltonian and the dynamics of quantum
walks is a unitary one so the
Hamiltonian will be adjacency matrix of
this graph or an increment to use and
then unitary evolution is given by
Schrodinger equation where the
exponential of the matrix is defined as
Taylor series but
the most natural way how to implement it
would be to we will be to go to
eigenbasis and then exponentiate matrix
trivially okay and continuous tank
quantum box has been studied at 102 in
last 10 years let's say fifteen and two
things which are interesting here is how
they evolve and spread this is one
picture where we started here in the
middle and we like the quantum walk
evolved on a line and this is how it
looked for quite short time and it
spread like this when the x was longer
and longer so you can see that the
distribution probability distribution
which can be made from the unitary
evolution is essentially different than
in then for random walks
we don't have binomial distributions
here but this strong peak at both ends
and also they spread faster than random
walks this property was used for for
algorithms and for going through named
trees and decision trees and also Andrew
child's and others showed that the
quantum walks are universal for
computation this is a new result which
is basically an exponential improvement
over the older paper so - so over
traversing through trees using quantum
walk with the we first we don't use
stage as single vertices from this crud
graph but columns as our portal here and
we define this comb subspace which can
be shown
it's invariant under action of
Hamiltonian which is adjacency matrix of
the whole graph so when we are in one
cone let's say this one and we applied
the Hamiltonian we will end up with in
these two neighboring columns as
expected so we can project the whole
graph on the line like this and we don't
have exponential many states as before
but only linear but to finish it the we
also need to find the weight of the
edges because the and this is how the
line finally looks like so the so all
edges have that square root of two
except for the middle one now this comes
from normalization of cones and except
calculation which is pretty
straightforward but quite boring so it's
easy to see that all these all edges in
this part will be equivalent and only
this edge can be somehow special and
that's exactly what we see here this is
the adjacency matrix of the line it's
free diagonal and the this is the inter
extinct part in the middle so we can do
unitary evolution when in this
Hamiltonian and it was shown that the
the this approach requires only
polynomial number of steps to reach the
exit vertex with sum 1 over N
probability but then we wanted to apply
this wanted to solve this
one with adiabatic with an adiabatic
algorithm because as I mentioned glue
trees are hard for a classical
computation but it they were solved
using quantum walks in quantum setting
so they they are an interesting example
of a distinction between quantum and
classical algorithms so firstly
time-dependent Hamiltonian we can we can
again so Schroedinger equation but
unlike in the common setting here the
Hamiltonian also depends on time so we
can't just exponentiate it directly but
we would need to slice the time into
many small pieces and in each small each
step we can evolve with Hamiltonian
which doesn't depend on time anymore
just for short time update our state and
update our Hamiltonian and evolve it
again so this sort of evolution is quite
complicated but we can again define
eigenstate but they will be different
for any time for for time but for any
time T we can there is an eigenbasis
which is complete and orthogonal and
moreover the we will use this notation
when we use relative time instead of all
time and the s relative time parameter
goes from 0 to 1 so although time depend
the evolutionary time dependent
Hamiltonian is is complicated there are
two two easy regimes the first one is
called diabetic
the total evolution time is very short
so we have initial Hamiltonian and very
fastly we will change it to two final
Hamiltonian so for example we have spin
in magnetic field and we turn the
magnetic field to opposite direction or
somehow else so in this case since the
time is so short the vague function and
the state doesn't change almost at all
so if we were in an eigenstate of the
initial Hamiltonian we'll be at the same
state after the evolution but it
probably won't be an eigenstate of the
final Hamiltonian anymore so we will end
up in some superposition of eigenstates
of the final Hamiltonian the complete
opposite is adiabatic regime when we
change the Hamiltonian very very slowly
and when we change it infinitesimally
small then the system reminds in it
again state or when we change it just
slow enough we will be close to the
eigenstate on or in our setting to the
ground state and if the change of the
Hamiltonian is smooth enough and it can
be normalized properly then we can show
that the time needed to reach the
adiabatic regime squares as 1 over the
minimal gap between the ground state and
the first excited state ok and ok so
this idea can be used in quantum
computation we start with an Hamiltonian
which can be easily prepared in a lab
and in in the ground state of it then we
change the Hamiltonian slowly to go to
the final Hamiltonian and if the change
is slowly enough compared to the minimal
gap we will end up in the ground state
of the final Hamiltonian which is
somehow interesting for our computation
and this way of computing is universal
as the return of showed okay so how can
we use adiabatic time evolution to solve
our grow trees the first thing we can
think about would be to start in enter
in the entrance and change the
Hamiltonian from projector to the
entrance to the projector of the exit so
firstly we project only on the enter and
then we project on the exit and how
evolution it's linear or let's say so
this simple approach doesn't work
because in the middle we encounter an
exponential a small gap another idea
which is pretty straightforward
is to start again in the entrance and
evolve to the ground state of adjacency
matrix of the trees but here we won't
have any problems with small gaps but
the ground state of adjacency matrix
isn't the ground state of isn't the exit
state even more it has only
exponentially small overlap with it but
we can combine these two approaches so
we take the projectors of n turn and
turn and exit and change them linearly
as in the first shot attempt but we add
the adjacency matrix in the middle to
help us overcome the the problematic
region
No
we have some some weights on this part
and this part and the ratio here is
important so if for example we set alpha
to 0 then we have the first attempt
which doesn't work which we have only
alpha then it doesn't work again as we
saw previously but maybe if we have both
parts here with some ways then we can
make it work and we will see and now we
see how the spectra differ for different
values of alpha and beta so this part
will be on verse 1 because we are
interested only in ratio and we changed
wages on projectors so we when we had
only only the adjacency matrix then we
have plot plot like this which looks
nice they are not exponentially small
gaps but it doesn't have the desired
ground state or practically it doesn't
do anything interesting at all and when
we start adding ending projectors then
we can see the distinction between
excited States and the ground state we
are here the grass stage will be the
projector on the entrance and here on
the exit but and there are some
complicated parts here here and also
when we make the projectors on on
entrance and edges even stronger we get
a complicated region also here so if we
turn out the the adjacency matrix in the
middle completely we would get cross
almost crossing exponentially small gap
as I told you before
okay but it's still it's still not clear
from plots of spectra so here are the
corresponding gaps with the logarithm
equals kind of the way exit so this is
the case only with adjacency matrix all
nice but doesn't work when we add
projectors we see two exponential Chalet
small gaps at the edges and these well
strong gaps at the edges and something
which looks more optimistic in the
middle and when we when we make weights
on edges even stronger then we have
sorry we have more more gaps in the
middle so from these pictures it might
seem that every time we do something
interesting we will have these nested
gaps here but in for this picture
it still looks quite optimistic because
these two gaps are symmetric and that's
what we are going to use so we allowed
us to differ from the start our dark
adiabatic scheme and jump here when we
can go slow enough through this gap we
instead of we decide to jump and go on
the first excited state in this region
and since it's all symmetric in this
part we are supposed to jump back so
that was our idea
okay we start in a ground state and we
want to go beyond the ground state up to
this power point with the exponential
gap then jump to the first excited state
here we need to go slow enough be
we don't want to propagate more to her
excited state and if all is symmetric at
the second gap we should jump again back
to the ground state and end in a ground
state oh this one okay this one these
two gaps are all the same you don't take
the job it's fine you're still in the
ground state everything still out here
yeah it doesn't know whether you take
that cap take thing take that any of
those lives will still lead you to the
same place
no here we will we need to jump because
the the gap is very small and we know
that if if we go faster then one over
the get squared will jump so what and we
can't go slow enough to stay here so
instead we say ok we don't care and we
jump here and if we go with the same
right here we will jump again to the
ground state is not obvious to the
ground States and asking the
yeah it's very unlikely that you jump
right I know she wants it to jump
because if it's likely that she'll jump
on the second time then if you don't
jump on the first time you go the wrong
way at the second time it's like two
wrongs make a right the other thing to
note think is be particularly the blue
curve Daniel you'll notice that the
brown curve actually is very smooth
approaching the blue curve yeah over
there so what actually happens at that
crossing is that that leads to an
extremely high probability of those
transitions happening no I understand
that I'm saying even if you didn't take
it it wouldn't matter no that's what I'm
saying it wouldn't matter because it
affects the one way because you're from
yet because there probably ain't gonna
go too wrong you tell me that I'll talk
to you later you need to jump down yeah
I understand the desirability I
understand why the first one matters in
the second one the second one I get why
it matters I don't understand the first
one so some of us play the back way
Thanks yes okay so first we needed to
analyze the whole spectrum analytically
so because I said okay this looks
exponential and this looks not so bad so
it will probably polynomial but we need
to know for sure and that's why we try
to compute spectrum of the of the
adjacency matrix it's quite similar as
the one from from gotras but we got
these two self loops at the entrance and
the exit vertex which some weights which
come from the ways between projectors
and the adjacency matrix of the glue
trees and also they will all be
different in different times so here we
use the trick with plane wave and such
because in this region it looks mostly
as a line it doesn't matter if we are in
this vertex or the next vertex our
neighbors are still the same and we know
that in case this is why this plane wave
and
of this form should work and and we get
an eigenvalue of this form so we applied
answers like this or like this in these
two parts and we with and some linear
allowed linear combinations of dit to
satisfy calm conditions also on the ends
and in the middle and solving couple of
equations we end with an equation for P
which is both trans and Delta but we
were still able so to solve it
analytically when and went to in the
limit of large n and from this we
computed the gaps exactly so this is how
the spectrum looks like when we take
everything in the account so firstly
here is the first gap exponential but
here the depth of trees isn't that large
so we can see that we don't have
crossings here but the gap in this
region turns out to be exponential and
scale like this the second gap is the
same as we solve so from plus and also
from symmetry of the adjacency matrix
and plot in and the gap in the middle
between the first excited state and the
second excited state squares only as one
over and cube so it's polynomial okay
so therefore if our write will be
somewhere between these between these
two limitations when we go this way we
will jump to the first excited States
because as Nathan said the it approach
here the connection is smooth
and increases here we don't want to jump
and in this part we will return again to
the ground set and we have an elliptical
result that the behavior is as I
mentioned but I will show only the one
from from our numerix so we start it in
the ground state and until we reach the
this point we were still in the ground
state here we went fast enough so the we
jumped almost 100% here and in the
middle region we lost some of population
on the first excited state but we had
still enough to reach the reach the
second jump place and return to the
ground state still with very high
probability so this is how it all work
like we solve this problem for grow
trees which is known to be exponentially
hard for any classical computers and
then we apply the ideas from quantum
walks from older papers and in the
adiabatic quantum computation but we we
didn't go through the classical to the
true the common adiabatic scam and we
didn't take the ground state all the
time but we jumped we started in the
ground state then jumped the first
excited state and jump back so this way
we came up with a new algorithm which in
which we had exponential gaps but we
didn't mind because of the symmetry with
this approach we gained exponential
speed-up
against classical
terms and we did it with a spare
Hamiltonian which is even more
stochastic although we didn't follow the
in the anylink regime so we didn't learn
more about the possibilities of
stochastic Hamiltonian in quantum in
quantum annealing and also there is the
question if we could use possibly jumps
for some other problems and to gain an
advantage over the way that people
thought before about adiabatic
computation so yeah that's all and thank
you for your attention
just kind of I get it the only comment I
was gonna make is if you went slower but
you don't want but if you went slower
and you would still follow you half on
the bottom it get there
it also go ridiculously fast before the
gap closed because you've got a long
break the first excited state then go
the optimal speed since you know where
that happens at that point then speed up
again as long as you don't go past that
polynomial gap in the middle and then
slow down to the right speed at the end
and then go as fast as you want you to
collapse out with the well I get it yeah
okay so you could you could optimize
this by using a local adiabatic schedule
yes yeah anywhere but near that
exponentially small way which is exactly
what we see in the stuff we've done the
the neat thing here was taking advantage
of the exponential closing and using it
to your advantage which that's cool
that's very cool
yeah one of the things I'd like that
I've been emphasized is just how hard it
was to find a good example of this I
remember I spent quite some time
struggling trying to make quantum
Fourier transform or
Sherlock algorithms try to work
naturally in an adiabatic setting and
made absolutely no progress this this
trick was was I think a really big
advance but we needed a symmetry to
break to overcome the problems with
exponential gaps which we don't have in
many common problems so nice to do next
mix those two to three schedule so you
can make it symmetric so is the symmetry
absolutely necessary in this case yes it
would need to go exponentially slow to
follow the the ground state all the time
because here you are promised that if
you jump then you will jump back in
later time only true in the case if you
schedule if you can one speed one
schedule it doesn't have to be symmetric
but you have to knowing the speed
besides the transmission yes well you're
gonna figure out a rate that was
computed on these right based on the gap
she built a function step number so it
said how fast that step was to go based
on yes certainly an energy right which
makes sense
and it's a Heisenberg so wouldn't that
be enough
the problem is generating is figuring
out what that function is but if you had
a function you could replace alpha beta
and all other stuff enemies occasion
we're supposed to with this continuous
or yeah with this function that tells
you how fast but if you infuse if you
think about it that's for the best that
you can end up getting out of this these
sorts of strategies save you plug into
Grover's search will get you you know a
polynomial into quadratics vina at best
and then go with in this case the
algorithm isn't particularly a practical
one so the key point is just showing the
exponential speed-up so you know about I
think these strategies could work but
it's not clear that for the purposes
here it's necessary this proved the
point this just really that's and that's
the whole decimal point in this out now
it is interesting do you really need a
perfect symmetry or just do you just
need to level crossing into levels and
you know I think can you steer yourself
through the state diagram effectively
they didn't appropriately how much
control can you really have at those
crossings
I suspected this question earlier and I
think that that that's one of the issues
with this work that hasn't been
addressed and correct me if I'm wrong
about that about you know the issues
about the sensitivity to small
deviations of the derivatives near the
crossing are avoiding Crossing yeah I
don't know but I would suspect that even
small deviation can you break the
symmetries if you if you can control
like maybe by coupling to a tea bath or
something if you can control where you
come out at when you go past the
crossing
you don't need symmetry at that point if
you can effectively steer your
approximation there's a get control of
diabetic evolution yeah but we still
need at least two gaps when we are one
get one giving the middle we have these
things at least a release of even
numbers
I guess we've started in an excited
that's right you started when you start
again how easy is to prepare I mean I
wouldn't say necessarily was starting to
serve with the answer
you know don't start at the beginning
start somewhere else